why are you so excited is it the best
season yet yes oh my god
[Music]
vesties in real life hilarious goofy and
super glamorous we're talking about the
cast of stranger things and we've got
the sweetest season three
behind-the-scenes moments to share with
you today watch until the end for the
funniest VTS joke ever put your hair in
a scrunchie crack open a can of new coke
and settle in for these adorable BTS
pictures that Netflix just released one
thing that's obvious in every photo is
that the cast had a blast making season
three we truly believe that it's a
fantastic season check out this picture
of Milly Bobby Brown in front of the rad
ad station wagon she's having the time
of her life nice to spenders eleven and
Billy is looking civilized and handsome
in his robe as he talks with the show's
creators caleb mclaughlin looks pretty
happy for a kid who's about to face the
upside down and we're not sure what
Charlie Heaton is looking at on the
monitor but he seems excited about it
hopefully it's not the end of his
character that he's witnessing this last
BTS pick has a squealing with
anticipation
the cast is huddled up with the deaf
brothers as they give direction on the
scene they are shooting at the star
court mall everyone looks so serious
speaking of interesting pictures if you
follow the stranger things Instagram
account pay attention to the profile
description they managed to write hi
you're Demi gorgeous upside down very
clever you guys the cast also shared a
cute video of them in the Good Morning
America greenroom right before they
appeared on the show caleb has the phone
as he is recording himself and the rest
of the gang as they wait to go on to the
show for their interview this video
shows that they are having a great time
together even after they finished
filming we can't get over how grown-up
they all are seriously caleb has facial
hair and all the voice voices have
changed as actors like you just have to
prepare for it
Milly and Sade you look gorgeous mini
fans tweeted about the fact that the
cast is so grown-up now one fan
commented on Caleb's mustache and wrote
that she is not ready for them to be
grown ups so much is going to change in
season three the cast of stranger things
has four
strong friendships with one another over
the course of three seasons they do
everything together
case in point Millie Bobby Brown posted
this pic of the crew together on
Halloween while Millie Sadie and Gaytan
went with Star Wars themed costumes
caleb dressed as a Rastafarian Millie
totally now the Princess Leia book but
by far our favorite Halloween costume is
Noah's he totally captured season mourn
11 all that's missing is an eggo in his
hand to complete the look and speaking
of sweet friendship moments we found
this picture of the cast locked up in a
group hug on set this is from the
stranger things TV Instagram account the
caption reads us hugging the kids when
they say they're not kids anymore this
looks like it throws all the way back to
season one when Elevens hair was super
short just look at how much they love
each other and their rights they
definitely are not kids anymore have you
ever watched a show and wondered if the
characters who play best friends are
actually besties in real life he's your
best friend right yeah well with Millie
Bobby Brown and Sadie Cink we don't have
to wonder at all Millie Bobby Brown
posted the best tribute ever to Sadie on
her Instagram profile she posted shots
of her and Sadie together making goofy
faces on Halloween blaming it up on the
red carpet hanging out on the beach and
then the cutest pic of Sadie who looks
like she just woke up the last shot is
one of Sadie with her red hair and an
Elvis curl in front of her face the
caption I'm Millie wrote has us all
shouting bestfriend goals
she wished Sadie a happy birthday Millie
also wrote that save his talents love
and kindness continued to surprise her
every day she added that they are more
than just best friends they are sisters
then she shared that they made a pact to
get married and moved to a farm in the
south of France she closed by saying
that reading this post makes her realize
how weird they are we hope they stay
best friends forever I think a lovin
needs to have a good relationship with
max that's my ultimate goal finally get
ready for the cutest funniest BTS
moments the cast of stranger things has
to offer it all started as sort of an
inside joke everyone was calling Steve
Harrington dad Steve it fits because
Steve definitely stepped into the
caretaker and protect your role in the
group it's not happening no no no no
buts he used himself as bait to help the
crew fight those demo dogs
he helps Dustin with his hair and gave
him some dating tips there you gonna go
there yeah look like a million bucks
yeah and he did all the heavy lifting
when he stuck that demo dog in the
refrigerator this just goes to prove
that Steve will do anything for these
kids so the creators of stranger things
made this awesome video featuring the
scene where Steve carries that gross
creature for Dustin and puts it in the
fridge during the scene they threw in an
80s guitar riff a title card slaps on
the screen that reads dad Steve on
Father's Day the cast took this joke
even further when they all made a
digital Father's Day card dedicated to
Steve Harrington it starts with a selfie
video of Gaytan wishing Steve a Happy
Father's Day
then it cuts to fin Wolford with an
equally adorable message until Nancy
dumped him but that he's still part of
the family the rest of the cast lists
off all the awesome dad stuff Steve has
done for Dustin and the rest of the gang
they wish him a happy Father's Day then
Finn says you're my dad now Steve
the funniest part comes at the end when
they put up a picture of Steve looking
exasperated and a title card that reads
happy Father's Day Steve which stranger
things character is your favorite sound
off in the comments and thanks for
watching the things be sure to subscribe
to catch all of our latest stranger
things videos and give this video a big
thumbs up if you love Elevens new look
see you next time
[Music]